quelles seront les conséquences du
coronavirus puisque 50 milliards de
produits chinois sont apportés chaque
année faut-il s'inquiéter at il un
risque de pénurie de médicaments ou de
produits en europe on entend plein plein
de choses il ya 30 à 40 % de touristes
en moins en france donc forcément ça va
ça va pénaliser beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes par an il ya environ 2 7
millions de touristes chinois qui
viennent en france 30 milliards de
dollars de pertes prévues pour les
compagnies aériennes
30 milliards de dollars c'est énorme un
milliard d'euros de pertes pour les
grandes entreprises françaises dans le
domaine du tourisme et de l'industrie
27% des vêtements vendus en france
viennent des usines de chine
et il ya aussi une pénurie de
médicaments possible alors quelles
seront les conséquences du coronavirus
qui qui peut répondre à cette question
en premier qui se sont dits répondre
yann moix les sociétés occidentales
notamment ne savent pas faire face à
l'invisible ce soit le terrorisme ou le
virus il ya un point commun c'est que
l'invisible nous échappent et les
bourses panique face à l'invisible
et comme l'a très bien dit karim tout à
l'heure il y a dans le dans la viralité
quelque chose d'extrêmement symbolique
or l'argent repose sur un consensus une
entreprise c'est repose sur le consensus
suivant que tout le monde croit la même
chose au même moment je suis qu'une
personne panique et l'édifice s'écroule
surtout dans des économies sont
interdépendantes donc la viralité allez
apprendre à tous les degrés viralité
sanitaire viralité symbolique viralité
monétaire les réalités géopolitiques et
ça contamine tout parent visibilité
c'est que ce qu'on voit pas et ferais
alors oui mais c'est sûr nicolas dupont
aignan justement je voulais me tourner
vers vous parce que tout à l'heure vous
avez dit quelque chose
vous avez dit on a on a confiné qu'elle
ait des personnes et puis on a laissé
rentrer beaucoup de touristes chinois
aussi parce que on s'inquiétait de
l'économie forcément il ya plein de gens
sur les réseaux sociaux je crois ce qui
tourne sur le film qui nous disent voilà
une fois de plus on va on va privilégier
l'économie a bien sûr à la santé qu'est
ce que vous en pensez de ça non mais je
pense en fait que c'est la
mondialisation qui est quand même à un
tournant et moi j'ai posé au premier
ministre une question sur la sphère des
médicaments il ya eu un rapport du sénat
effrayant vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il
ya seulement 10 % 10 % 1 sur 10 des
médicaments remboursés par la sécurité
sociale qui sont produits en france
c'est 80 % sont produits en asie
et tout ça pour quoi c'est parce que
l'état a laissé les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques faire du fric sur le
remboursement de la sécurité sociale
ça fait des années que j'alerte sur ces
délocalisations des principes actifs
les trente cinq principaux principes
actifs pour le cancer sont produits en
chine
c'est une folie il arrivait d'une
religion politique c'est une non
seulement raison il a raison de s'en
méfier
alors il y en a juste lui aura sans
doute un avant et un après bien sûr et
la mondialisation est un coup dans le
nez ça oui au palais site où mahomet il
ya des entreprises je me souviens va
rencontrer un
un patron d'une entreprise
pharmaceutique dans le loiret qui
m'avait expliqué ça il ya dix ans et il
m'avait dit ils vont tout délocaliser ya
plus de contrôle de l'état et c'est
l'argent plus public c'est l'argent de
nos cotisations sociales donc moi je ne
demande pas qu'on fasse tout en france
bien sûr mais c'est un rééquilibrage et
je cette crise mais sa part claude
sureau servir ici on peut moins que ça
des régions exactement tirer les leçons
pour relocaliser mais ce crime il faut
et fort ok mais ça c'est encore ce un
problème économique mais ça va du coût
de l'heure moins cher le plus oui mais
excusez moi je vous le dit profit des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques soit -20%
je suis d'accord fixant à 12% c'est par
là je suis d'accord avec vous ici
fogolin servir à ça un accroc sera très
bien se trouver
il faudra un moment dire on reprend en
main la santé soit pas dire toujours su
allier je suis pas un connard meshaal
apporte une bonne idée mais oui mais
vous pouvez pas laisser web la recherche
pour la santé aux mains des actionnaires
alors ce qui risque d'avoir une pénurie
de médicaments de re nationale papou n'a
pas pour l'instant on est des gens
pénurie tenir pour l'instant mais
effectivement c'est arrêter un vrai
souci d'indépendance si je peux dire ou
d'autonomie de la france et de l'europe
en général
moi je voudrais juste rajouter un point
qui peut paraître technique c'est que au
bout de dix ans un médicament ne peut
devenir non pas peu de vert devient un
générique d'accords devient gênant
puisque la propriété industrielle et
perdu 10 15 ans c'est comme ça et donc à
partir de ce moment là les génériques
sont fabriqués en plus grande quantité
dans des pays ou des plus facile de les
fabriquer voilà pour être
plus claire possible le moins obscur
possible exactement donc à partir de ce
moment là c'est vrai que ces médicaments
génériques que l'on utilise
systématiquement tous les jouets qui
vont qui nous sont pratiquement imposé
par la sécurité sociale pour des pour
des raisons d'efficacité mais également
d'économies sont fabriqués en dehors de
l'europe et ça pose un problème
dernière chose on n'est pas là parce
qu'il a pas de traitement pour le corps
un peu que l'ordre c'est quoi le
d'ailleurs c'est quoi le traitement
problème a pas on fait quoi quand on
accorde avions des bateaux et médicale
alors dites-nous professeur de
thérapeutique expérimental et donc c'est
le rhône à terme expérimental que l'on
s'échange au niveau international et
l'agencé du médicament française
récupère les médicaments il ya un
produit qui a là mêmes qui est un
produit qu'on utilisait dans l'infection
vih s'appelle lopinavir ritonavir qui
par la bouche qui a été utilisée par
certains patients hospitalisés en france
et un deuxième qui s'appelle leur md et
vire qu'on avait développé dans la
maladie à virus ebola et qui est par
voie intraveineuse sur dix jours qui est
plus complexe qu'on réserve aux formes
graves et que l'on récupère deux sur un
marché mondial via le laboratoire via l'
agence du médicament avec un et on est
bien équipée sur ces de zi qar ou
médicaments pas nous allons avoir une
pénombre il n'y a pas de stock d'état il
faut réguler au cas par cas puisque le
laboratoire va donner aux pays qui
reçoit des formes graves etc
l'oc cesson les deux traitements
aujourd'hui actuellement ces deux
traitements et qui sait vraiment vous
qu'il accorde à son tour et une personne
a le coronavirus elle se présente à vous
vous faites quand vous dites vous avez
mal à tête vous avez des problèmes
respiratoires qu'est-ce que comment vous
la dirai donc vous le verrez comment
vous lui dites vous à évaluer la gravité
on va évaluer la gravité si c'est une
forme non graves qui ressemble à une
petite grippe bénigne qui a aucun
critère de sévérité
on va lui donner un traitement contre la
douleur contre la fièvre si les plus
graves
elle va devoir suppléa sa respiration
avec de l'oxygène des techniques de
ventilation et s'il a la forme et nous
embête pas ce qu'il ya vraiment des
critères de gravité on va tenter avec
son accord bien sûr que le volontariat
du patient un traitement expérimental
alors va surveiller juste si on a déjà
eu le corps d'un virus qu'on peut avoir
une deuxième fois alors ça devrait être
ça c'est une bonne question sur le plan
immunologique on en peut on ne peut pas
répondre à ce stade
sauf que actuellement on peut will i am
il y à quelques travaux qui montre mais
sans rentrer dans les détails techniques
que le le nombre de mutations le niveau
de mutation du virus n'est pas très très
élevé donc à partir du moment où vous
avez développé une réponse normalement
devrait compter sans la première
interaction ou être protégé d'un
deuxième d'accord a priori étant donné
le recul on à qui le ministre de la
santé il ya une question
ouais ce matin et le ministre de la
santé ne l'a pas confirmé a dit qu'il ne
savait pas en fait ça parce que c'est la
grande banque au japon et un cas où
j'arrivais notable a tout récemment qui
aurait été nominée deux fois d'accord ce
qui pose un vrai problème auparavant les
vaccins à compter ça s'appelle un
précieux qu'est ce que je fais mes
toiles des connaissances on peut le dire
on peut plus les symptômes respiratoires
problèmes respiratoires respect c'est ça
si on aime tant de problèmes
respiratoires
c'est vrai que ça peut être maintenant
le problème qui à l'épidémie en étant
pic d'épidémie de la grippe saisonnière
et ça donc on est en pic d'épidémie de
la grippe d'où l'importance si je peux
me permettre
mais des médecins libéraux qui ont
besoin d'être associé complètement les
forts parce que si on ne se concentre
que sur l'hôpital et d'où l'importance
de les trouver que je suis un
obsessionnel sur les masses et les
instruments de protection mais les
médecins libéraux ont besoin d'urgence
de pouvoir être en relais parce que
sinon l'hôpital public alors est encore
plus débordés c'est à chacun et se hisse
médecins par exemple étant pas notre
relation avec le samu et quand ya des
cas un peu suspect mais pas fort oui on
verrait on en voit un médecin des sceaux
est médecin au domicile s'équiper
correctement les médecins des serial
killers donne plus de mains des médecins
libéraux rice et le médecin en première
ligne qui accorde efforts qui sont en ce
moment est bien arrivé à la fin les mots
n'arrivent à se soigner à la pitié
sérieux le faire vous êtes sur le
terrain toute la journée c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on sent qu'ils aient une
certaine psychose
voilà deux mois je vois des potes dès
qu'ils ont un petit peu mal à la tête
ils sentent pas bien dans la journée ils
ont même ils tous un peu une 10 je pense
que j'ai le coronavirus à ce qu'elle
avait des gens qui se présentent à vous
comme ça tu as quand même et c'est vrai
dire on y pense tous maintenant dès
qu'on a un truc on pense qu'on a le
corona virus donc le mot qui convient
peut-être des pets fort aujourd'hui
d'accord il inquiétude réelle dans notre
pays psychose sont encore aujourd'hui
comment tu as des inquiétudes ya un
numéro qui est mis à disposition de la
population
et il nous a été rapporté que il ne
fonctionne pas il est difficile à être
joignable ça c'est le fameux saturé
aussi d'appel du numéro vert d'accord je
constate un je ne critique pas je fais
simple assure une constatation que le 0
800 aujourd'hui la personne arrive à
faire la constatation à l'utiliser je ne
critique pas qu'on s'entende bien par
contre une psychose non mais des
inquiétudes des inquiétudes d'accord oui
c'est avant hier avant l'épidémie en
italie je vous assure tous les jours moi
je travaille comme le collègue et
personne ne parlait du cornât virus
jusqu'à ce week-end dernier et servait
deux patients qui n'ont pas l'eau est-ce
que vous pensez que hélas depuis
l'épidémie honnêtement malgré tout faut
reconnaître que les gens sont assez
raisonnables
il n'y a pas une panique extraordinaire
j'ai vu plein de grimm j'en vois tous
les jours et personne ne me dit je suis
d'abord le corps d'un virus donc
finalement les gens ils sont pas si on
voit c'est que ça ils arrivent quand
même à faire la part des choses il faut
quand même le salut